bist du noch luft lauf lauf lauf lauf
läuft columbia economy ecce meine maus
ist nach dieser change sowas von
kaputter hits willkommen zu einer neuen
folge jump li zusammen mit von heute
werden bevor de los reyes gar nicht los
wird er nicht los beruhigt mich beruhigt
leute werden im letzten video die maus
sensitivität sky hoch gestellt und heute
gehts runter ganz in den keller und
bestehe jetzt die maus die sensitivität
so weit runter wie es geht
macht das war bei dir ok jetzt auf 800
dpi bei der maus und jetzt kannst du in
minecraft nummer steuerung und da oben
aus gefälligkeit 800 das minimum bei dir
ist es unfair aufgehen bin auf 180 mehr
bewegt sich nichts leute ich muss mit
den tasten springen ich meine maus kann
man muss echt bewegen
ich bin auf 100 dpi und johann ich kann
meine maus nicht bewegen ich bin ich bin
auf 800 dpi und jahren ich bei mir ist
es mega kritisch du das auch auf 800
hoch wenn du willst mach ich muss
schauen ob dort künftig ist auch machen
leute die gar wenn ich im inventar wenn
es die maus wieder schnell klar dass es
ein bisschen schneller glaube ich ja
warum ist es so ich muss da sowieso
kurve auf dem mauspad nachgerade
leute hört ihr das ich mein mauspad aber
mehr als modul ist relativ friedlich nie
die maus bewegen wenn du rennst du hast
nur du laufen mussten die maus bewegen
was wirklich aus nein ich hatte jetzt
weiß ich auch nicht was ist dass man es
einfach schon bei 50 prozent lag
schon guten dafür nächstes hält sich so
ein bisschen grenzen möglich oder denkt
ihr geht schon wenn man eine
funktionierende maus hat ist dass man
sein ist aber bei 59 prozent
nein ich schwöre ich schaffe nicht mal
das erste springen
also das kann man auch seitwärts
springen kann man okay leute
märz ist cool cool cool ich würde wenn
ich jetzt den vertrag ja jetzt geschaut
die pro gamer alter und wie ja aber ja
gut leute leute hält jetzt sehen kugel
muss die ecke zu kommen
nach oben neue leute man muss hier so
viel hast dich so sehr nach es ist so
übel
ok modul 33 habe ich auch schon bin ich
schon okay das kannst du kannst ganz gut
seitlich springen also ohne maus einfach
geht jetzt vor der küste nach der kiste
den sprüngen schaffe ich nie von der
kiste aus ich muss da immer zurückgehen
43 hatte ich bin auch ich glaub ich bin
ich beim modul 4 ich weiß nicht wer hier
kugel müssen ach du fucking verlass mich
dass ich einmal angekurbelt werden ich
vermisse ich muss ich muss gar nicht mal
so schlecht wir sind letzter nein jetzt
der fall
oder aber wir müssen etwas überlegen für
das match in kurven kurbel kurbel und
online ein modul 5 ist ein krasser
richtungswechsel acht stunden lang
nichts und dann hat mir genau
mitgenommen was ich hab fast an meiner
maus und wenn ich so hart kurbeln
wirklich so zusammen ist die ganze taste
drückt und ich rollen dort warum bin
verrückt
okay okay man muss ja immer vorsprung
ausrichten und möglich keine sprünge
jawohl ja wollte ich habe stein schweiz
sogar ich glaube du bist neben mir kann
es dann aber nach rechts waren ein
bisschen hart sagt ja das ist die taktik
ist aber ein team betrifft nicht nur die
länder an das schiff ist echten
teamkollege jedem kam das team lobbys
bitte denken sie sind die solo heroes
wir haben ungefähr so die die wendigkeit
von 40 tonner lkw wenn ich würde ich
jetzt also schnellzug ist als ob alle
fenster fällt wie machen wir machen
müssen da jemand wie ich bin angezogen
da ist brüssel gegner
ok also probieren es erstmal so dr
ich kann mich nicht drin das ist so
präsentiert getötet
das läuft auf knopf lauf lauf kommen um
die ecke komme merke meine maus ist nach
dieser technisch so was für kaputte
hätte meine kleinen kreativen geht ihr
typ machten team übrigens einen anderen
typ noch ich haben die tür gelegt vorher
hat ich hätte mich als titelthema dessen
team von teilweise über brauchen ok ok
ich muss erst mal kekse essen auf die
auf der gleichen gegend ziehen
nein nein die laufwerke laufwerk mit der
fünf karten gucken vielleicht kann ich
noch hinten schlagen hey du kannst du
mit etwas glück ich ganz gutes tradegate
ich dreh mich am arsch ja ja oder oder
gerade os x der hektik und sich darum zu
drehen was ich das kann nichts machen
wir mit wie viel leben hast du eins noch
der experten ja ich weiß auch nicht wo
bist du gerade
ich bin mir den ruin man weiß es nicht
ich bin bei dieser eine brücke da oben
ich bin dann kann ich das erklären wo
ich bin
das ist so gemein habe ich im cockpit
ich hole ich hab noch nie gemacht mein
gott dankbar jetzt lauf lauf lauf
bekommen ihr land allein die kurbel ich
kurve zu gast ach du scheiße wie krass
wie sie kommen also man als ob sie nur
einen weg rein und raus gibt ja was ist
daraus ich kann mir für nachtarbeit
entwickeln diesmal nicht behindert du
kannst dich auf den boden klicken neben
einem kino zu bekommen
überlegt kann man kann man das irgendwie
machen dass man das ding hier waren
scheinen hause warten wir müssen
irgendwie treffen müssen sowie treffen
wir sind ganz so beides sowohl werbespot
versteht was hier nicht wie spot
ballack ist wie es mir geht ich spiele
das hier bist du das dfb team tipp tipp
chemietanker mit chemie jetzt um die
ecke kommen und er gekoppelt wo gott
hinter mir was ich war gerade beim sport
auf jeden fall aber der wahre gegner
glaube ich gott provokant wechsel auf
mit der einer in ihr schwert das ist
nicht wahr
der befassung die erschwert kann ich dir
meine koordinaten sagen bekommst du ja
ich bin ich bin nicht ich bin oder
20.000 ich bin dauernd weil gott oh gott
ein termin ist einem schwert und der
andere typ mediabiz.de wenn ich schlau
sind kreise mich jetzt ein sind so
schlau ist adressiert war
was aber halbes jahr ist halbes leid ich
bin doch ich weiss nicht läuft sie ganz
und gar nicht lang war der taktik wir
bleiben hier und wir bleiben hier bis
die kommen und dann plötzlich feuer
ein bisschen was schon drei tage später
hatte ich bin mal ein bisschen lockvogel
vorne vielleicht kommen die burgart pass
auf wissen wir sind nicht halt nicht sie
halten sich somit werden haben ein
riesenproblem bisschen umgedreht haben
wir dürfen nie irgendwo weglaufen weil
sie können ihn intern machen den fehler
hab ich zwei mal gemacht ich bin
deswegen zweimal gestorben wir müssen
einfach drauf und bisschen einmal
versuchen zu user uns treffen kann ich
eigentlich gar nicht so
das kann nicht wahr sein ich hab ich
einen trecker ausgenommen also ich
erkennen wohin ich weiß wir uns aber wir
dürfen nie irgendwo hin wo wir umdrehen
müssen oder sonst wer also wie man
notfalls können wir schon ein bisschen
drehen glaube ich kann es und wenn jetzt
kommen die reise ich mit der anderen die
erschwert was dem ich nicht gesehen
jung gewesen so fakten die sich
irgendwann oder so
oder überleben noch zwei minuten geht es
laut iggy die kommen mit dem das gibt's
doch nicht
wir müssen erstmal erholen
glaub ich auch was ist los man aber das
war auf jeden fall sehr sehr witzig ihr
weniges unten verlinkt und wir machen
change auf seinem kanal aufgenommen
checkt die ab schaut rüber zu ihm man
weiß nicht wann sie kommt wahrscheinlich
die tage mal also abonniert alle wenig
kraft punkt at